fourth down and goal
and the play clock is down at three and
here we go and wilson throws caught
and it is going to be hollister
this is total insanity the previous play
will go under review we'll go back to
the inception of the play hollister
gets taken down ooh
oh it looks short to me say he was
across the line it's just the opposite
of the atlanta game that they s holy cow
completed past receiver was down short
of the goal line
san francisco will take over
first down what a way for the 100th year
to end
that really was a way for the nfl's
100th regular inches game of inches just
like the falcons 49ers game from a
couple of weeks ago in that case though
the ball kissed all it has to do is kiss
the goal line any part of it the front
of it any part of the ball crosses that
front touches that front of the
touchdown it was so close credit to dray
greenlaw for the tackle that he made big
time at the goal line to keep jacob
hollister out it was a crazy final
sequence it felt inevitable the seahawks
were going to win that game as they were
getting closer and closer to the goal
line there was just this sense building
and and i wanted a play from the one i
needed a play from the one and it looked
like for a brief moment in time we were
gonna get a play from the one well i
mean we should have got a play from the
one three plays before that but somehow
seattle forgot there's a play clock in
the national football league so that's
where we checked the rulebook i checked
the rulebook
there's
i mean the funniest that's the first
time you've ever said that where it's
actually accurate yes yes well i the
funniest thing about it i seriously was
explaining the play clock to my wife
like within with the two to three plays
before this because she's still learning
football even though she's been around
it for 20 years now but regardless that
was a huge moment too you spike the ball
and then have no plan of attack the
spike the ball let's reset it too 42
seconds left fourth and 10 on the san
fran 12. the pass was completed inside
the one you got the first knight to get
the first down butt tick tick tick tick
right and it just seemed like they're
okay says spike the ball that's no
there's no problem with that i get it
but then it just seemed like the seattle
seahawks sideline was flustered as far
as what personnel what to do and yeah
and then they got no plays from the one
which led to the series of events there
and the last play being that but just i
think the biggest thing that jumps out
to me is just how close the nfl is it's
crazy i mean that's the difference
between a home playoff game for the
seahawks and now going on the road to
philadelphia the 49ers who had a fourth
and two and we're down to the saints
they make that play and then this play
right here and that's the difference
between them having to be on the road in
a fifth seat and a home field advantage
so uh just an amazing amazing year
amazing to finish the 100th season that
way and an awesome game last night
because i thought the 49ers gonna kind
of run away with it at one point let's
get back to that last sequence yeah
because the 49ers
were able to keep the ball out of the
end zone on that that fourth and 10 play
from the 12. the seahawks rushed to the
line of scrimmage george fant was
injured he had the hustle to get up
there so that the ball could be spiked
and if you're watching on nbcsn you'll
see the full sequence but that delay of
game that's inexcusable an excuse right
and what pete carroll said after the
game is there were no backs to play
before we called the personnel and just
didn't get it communicated with the
backs and we were just late and i don't
know that i buy that because marshawn
lynch was out on the field reacted i
remember seeing him go out too you're
right i i mean i i mean i don't know i
mean yes it was a little late getting on
the field for sure but it still seemed
like seattle had no clue i mean they
were in the huddle still when they had
to call the timeout so they it's like
they had lost track of like oh there's a
play clock we're down at the one it's
really exciting blah blah blah i mean
it's almost like the super bowl of 49
against the page
and here's my theory yeah they
they got all twisted up right here they
are at the one right key moment marshawn
lynch is in yeah should we run the ball
what do we do yeah we better get this
right what do we got earlier we got to
get this right right right um i i
you everybody's aware of that five years
later and i feel like they were hyper
aware of it they were so aware of it
that they forgot
that little clock in the end zone that
works its way down to zero because it
was like it wasn't even a consideration
usually you'll see
at some point somebody realizes oh crap
let's go
and that never happened it was just like
an afterthought oh oh yeah that oh yeah
double zeros oops five yards back yeah
it totally caught them by surprise i
mean russell wilson looked surprised in
the huddle when they called timeout so
that was it was inexcusable and yeah
that wasn't the end of it it was not
they still had chances they still had
chances but their chances would have
been greater from the one and yeah okay
i i still don't know if you can run run
the ball there i mean we know that
that's going to be dicey right but right
because if you no timeouts no you're not
you're right you're you're probably
screwed you maybe get to run one more
play and that's it so yeah i understand
that too but your chances and your
playbook are different on third and one
and play action i mean from the one-yard
line and play actions available too and
bootlegs are available and sprint passes
and things like that that are not going
to be available now when you're at the
six yard line so i think that was the
big thing overall action of marshawn
lynch well whatever it may be you know
yeah he ran it in from the one already
you fake it to him up the middle russell
wilton bootlegs out and they're so
expecting marshawn up the middle that
you know they don't cover somebody who
knows what happened there was a play
there was a play earlier in the game
that felt like an express nod to super
bowl 49 where it looked like it was
gonna be a run to marshawn lynch
and they either did a fake handoff or a
fake pitch and then they set it up they
were gonna throw it to him but he was
covered right but i just feel like
forget about super bowl 49 just just
flush that for good don't let that hover
over you when you get to the one yard
line and that was marshawn lynch's first
game back in a long time and i can stand
why it was an issue sure but uh but even
then right what did you think of the
third and goal play from the five where
jacob hollister and fred warner made
contact in the end zone there was no
full-blown replay review for pass
interference right al river on the
senior vp of officiating told a pool
reporter after the game that they looked
at it but didn't trigger the full-blown
we're going to take a close look at it
did you see anything there that made you
think there may have been defensive
passengers well definitely you know and
it's not the initial contact because
again like fred warner linebackers they
have the right to the space they're in
hollister runs into them and here it is
on tv if you're watching on tv so i have
no problem with the initial contact my
problem is once hollister pulls away
without a doubt fred warner's
interfering he's holding with his left
arm jacob hollister's right arm and with
fred warner's right arm he has his right
hand on jacob hollister's shoulder so i
mean from what we saw this year that to
me looked like it was a
going yeah
terry mccauley said it i i would think
the nfl is going to look at this i mean
that was one to me where it looked clear
and obvious where i would just go oh
they're gonna they're gonna overturn
this it's gonna be pi and they're gonna
get the ball at the one yard line again
i mean that's what i was thinking when i
originally saw the play what was your
thought yeah i look it was it wasn't
blatant it wasn't egregious it's one of
those that's gonna fall into that gray
area where you'll wonder how aggressive
will al riverrun and the league office
be
in the postseason with plays like this
because as regular season plays go this
was as significant as any could be with
all the different ramifications and all
the tentacles you've got the saints who
got screwed by this non-call because
they lose their buy
packers
right right although the packers i said
this earlier they can't be all that
upset because it's like complaining
about a really good christmas gift that
it wasn't good enough being that i was
better than them being the two seed for
them is pretty damn good but for the
saints now they have an extra round they
have an extra level they have to play
and then they have to go on the road so
the saints have to look at it and say
what the hell the seahawks look at it
and say what the hell and and we still
all year long have never gotten full
clarity on when and how
this rule is going to be used every time
and every time it's used we get the
magic words we get the abracadabra
but sometimes the abracadabra doesn't
mesh with everything that happened
before it and we just are expected to
accept it and move on and forget what
our lying eyes may be telling yeah well
that's that's my problem with this rule
in general i just think they need to get
rid of it it's it's it's just causes
issues here we are it was a great game
but we're going to spend two or three
minutes on that because
like you always say 50 guys in a bar i i
would bet you more than half thought
that was past interference uh for sure i
would say probably 40 to 50 40 out of
the 50 are gonna say that's past
interference so uh yeah it's just
annoying that we got to constantly talk
about it and deal with it uh and i wish
they would just not review uh review
past interference at all going forward
until they figure out a better way to do
it and even with all that yeah russell
wilson went back to the jacob hollister
well on the fourth down play and dre
greenlaw
what a stop at the goal i mean this was
the gift that kept on giving
there were like 10 last play you know 10
gr moments all crammed into that final
seattle never dies
hollister if greenlaw does not make that
tackle at the goal line the ball touches
the plane the ball does enough that it's
a touchdown and the 49ers lose and the
seahawks win right what a finish that
was
unbelievable that's it
goes he went high right which i do agree
with stats there like the fact that he
goes high stops all momentum and the
ball is spotted there instead of like if
he tried to take his legs out or hit him
in the knees hollister's probably going
to fall forward and end up in the end
zone how much of that
that we saw last night yeah
is the product of poaching points that
emerged when julio jones got the ball in
two weeks ago could be it seemed like a
very similar coverage uh as far as what
they were doing and i'd like to break it
down more and probably will for my
podcast later but you know definitely
teaching this show i can't tell
everybody
i need to see the film i mean i just
need that but yes regardless uh the one
thing i'll say that it probably did for
the san francisco 49ers more than
anything was prepare them when they're
in that coverage that they're very
susceptible in that area to that route
and if you go back and guys if we could
show that play one more time from the
start there like you can see greenlaw
okay from the start of this play he is
out there but his eyes are across the
field if you watch him here mike like go
ahead check him out here he's so roll
the tape green laws at the on the top
hash there basically look he's shuffling
to his left but look how quick his eyes
came back across the field as russell
wilson was throwing the ball he was very
prepared for it to have that body
presence there takes one more step to
the left and it's gonna be seahawks wins
seahawks wins packers of the one seed
saints of the two seed it comes it
really is amazing the 256 games can come
down
to that
but the 49ers were the better team at
least in my opinion that's where i do
believe that is where it's it's easier
to swallow with a bad pass interference
call the 49ers had many chances to put
the game away early and just like we've
seen here in recent history in the nfl
when you don't put teams away and
especially great quarterbacks away like
your vikings didn't do to aaron rodgers
on monday night again a few weeks ago or
the lions yesterday to aaron rodgers
right it's just same thing with russell
wilson here here you go you're going man
the 49ers controlled this game the
seattle seahawks defense couldn't stop
them but they keep giving russell wilson
the ball he keeps converting third downs
and making great throws on the sidelines
of dk metcalf and you're going here they
go they're going to go down the field
and score a touchdown yeah it really was
a great game and the 49ers are the
better team and you know what the way
that the dominoes fall we may see a
rematch of the seahawks and the 49ers we
may be there for that one divisional
round or it could be conference
championship right depending upon the
way things all play out
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports